what's going everyone in this video i'm
going to show you the number one mistake
um that i made and that i see a lot of
entrepreneurs making in terms of how to
make money from
more money from their business so the
number one metric
that i track for our businesses is this
one and you may not even have heard this
one
but i think it is the most important and
warren buffett agrees with me
all right it's net free
cash flow all right say it and then
imprint it into your minds
all right and obviously this depends on
what type of business you're running
but what net free cash flow is is the
amount of money
that an owner of a business can take out
of the business after
the business reinvests in staying ahead
of the competition
and maintaining its competitive
advantage right and so
the problem with the vast majority of
businesses and or business owners
is that what they do is at some level i
mean the first problem is that many of
them don't make any profit right so
that's probably like problem number one
and when you say
i'm reinvesting the business and the
reality is that you're not making a
profit
you need to be real with yourself that's
probably what's happening
category two is the type of businesses
that are making a profit
but then they take that profit and they
reinvest it back into the business
now i'm not saying that this is
necessarily a bad idea
i'm saying that for me in my
entrepreneurial experience
i like to take money out of businesses i
like to make money while i'm growing
businesses
and this comes hard learned because in
my first
five years when i started my businesses
at the time
i was starting gyms i had an online
fitness coaching business too
whenever i would make money from my gym
i would open up
another location which sucked right
um i mean it sounds great and but i was
asset rich
and cash poor all right and that made a
pretty problem that you were suffering
from too
i had equipment i had leases i had
flooring i had signage i had lobbies i
had front desks i had glass walls i had
all of the things except for
money in my bank account and what ended
up happening is i
actually at after after
three four five whatever years it was um
when i
sold those companies i ended up getting
out of them
relatively quickly and i took all the
money i got from those sales which i
would consider like short sales they
were kind of garage sales i pretty much
sold them as assets
rather than as businesses because i
wanted to do this new thing which was
gym launch
um but what ended up happening though is
i took all that money and i went into a
new venture so
gym launch happened after this but there
was a little period of time there where
i
uh did something new with a partner that
i thought was gonna be partnered with
and i'll just say in short terms it
didn't work out
and so what ended up happening is i
didn't get a ton of money for
the gyms that i sold and then all that
money disappeared
and at that moment i promised myself i'm
never making the mistake this mistake
again because what ended up happening is
that after all those years and all that
you know all that time and the money
that i had made all of it was gone
i was like i've made millions at that
point dollars in revenue
right and i had i had nothing
you know what i mean and so i see this a
lot
and the thing is is that a lot of us
entrepreneurs have this dream that
someday we're going to sell
the reality is the chips are stacked
against you all right
99 of businesses don't get sold ever
right and so this idea that we're going
to have this mythical exit someday
right for most businesses isn't true and
of the of the businesses that it is true
many of those exits aren't as sexy as
they may sound like
right like i technically exited those
businesses but it wasn't like
you know i wasn't set for life right you
know what i mean i think it was
like multiple it was like 200 grand 300
it wasn't a lot of money
um that i made from those i think i sold
all in all
uh covering partnerships and all that
stuff i think i all in
got 200 grand i think for selling six
locations like it was just not a lot
right and
if you've been doing this for years then
that exit if you've been like i've been
doing this
at that time i think for four or five
years like that's like 40 grand a year
right if i had been just ripping cash
out of the business and stacking it the
whole time
i would have had a lot more money than
that at that point right and so
this is a mistake that i see a lot of
entrepreneurs make is that they're not
focused on this
net free cash flow right they're not
thinking how can i take money out of
this business
every single year how can this business
pump out profits
while i still continue to grow it and
some of that also comes from the
expectation of how
quickly i want to grow so a lot of times
we want to grow really fast for no
reason only the arbitrary reasons that
we set for ourselves and the
expectations of others that we project
right but there's really no reason to do
it but we end up just growing
irresponsibly
and then in so doing do it wastefully
and
expose ourselves to higher risk and more
mistakes and in the process also lose
the one thing
that we get along the way if you do it
the right way which is net free cash
flow as in like getting paid to grow
your business
i remember i sat down with some of my
employees um probably eight years ago i
was actually at the gyms
and i think they had said that they
wanted to get a raise or something like
i can't remember what it was
and i was like do you understand the
difference between like imagine working
for an entire month
right working your ass off every hour of
the day right
and then at the end of the month not
only did i not pay you
i just cleaned out your savings for
working that hard
and they're like yeah that would suck
and i'm like that happens to me all the
time
right and so that's the thing is we take
on so much risk
and you start to get used to the risk
because you've just been doing it for
such a long time
but you have to reward yourself for the
risk that you were taking
all right now um the reason that i like
net free cash flow is that it focuses
the entire company on not just making a
profit but making a profit in excess of
what is required to continue to run
and grow the business all right and so
um this is the number one stat that i
look at
this is what i have my financing report
on for all of our entities
because this is the real real this is
owner earnings
this is what warren buffett and charlie
munger calculate with the companies that
they want to buy because they're like
we hate companies where we buy them and
then we take all the profit and have to
reinvest all that money back into the
same business
right they're like that sucks that's why
they said they don't like manufacturing
and they don't like
a lot of types of companies where you
have to have all these capital expenses
meaning
money expenses that you buy big stuff
that you you know depreciate over time
they're like that sucks right and so
um net free cash flow is the stat that i
track
and if you're interested at all um i was
reading a book recently called uh the
little book that beats the market really
good book you can read in one sitting
really fascinating actually and he
posits
that there are only two metrics that are
really important
for tracking for really getting above
average returns all right
the first is the p e ratio which is the
price to earnings ratio
and if you think about what warren
buffett talks about in terms of buying
businesses he says you want to buy good
businesses for cheap prices
right so the figuring out whether it's a
cheap price is going to be the price to
earnings ratio how much how much
net free cash flow how much how much
earnings is this company creating not
that those are the same thing but i'm
saying generally right
um how much how many what's the earnings
of this company and what's the price for
those earnings
all right so this is number one so
ideally you want a really low price for
really high earnings
now the second thing is
uh return on capital and so what that
means is
now imagine a company that has i'll give
you two scenarios let's say we've got a
company
that um you know let's say they make a
million dollars in profit
and when they reinvest a million dollars
in profit into their company uh let's
say it's opening locations just for
whatever reason right so
they open a new location and fro it cost
them a million dollars open location and
then that location
gets them a hundred thousand dollars a
year in additional earnings all right
that's a 10 return on capital right
that's what that means now let's take an
alternative scenario let's say that
another company
um for a million dollars can open 10
locations
and each of those locations can do 100
000 a year
right that would be a 100 return on
capital
and so the beauty of these two metrics
is
the pe the price to earning ratio tells
you this is a
is the price of the business we're
buying this is a cheaper business
right the return on capital tells us the
quality of the business that we're
buying
which is how good is this business a
great business is a business that can
take a small amount of money
and generate lots of cash from it right
and so by combining these two things
finding the companies that have the
lowest p e ratio with the highest return
on capital
you can consistently beat the market
that was kind of the premise of the book
which actually really interesting they
um they used this algorithm that did
these two things
and they beat the the s p 500 which is
basically i want to say impossible
it's it's very difficult to do for most
people and they beat it for i think like
25 years which is nuts by a big
percentage which was crazy the thing is
is that the companies that are usually
in this bucket
are usually companies that are going
through issues and so you're basically
buying mispriced bets
right and half the companies that you
buy that that meet these two
qualifications end up tanking
but the other half that might have had
some bad press because of something are
disproportionately
discounted in pricing and as a result
in the future they they outperform uh
the price that you're paying for them
right
and so to to bring the wagon back around
here
as business owners net free cash flow is
my home base
this is what i care about this is the
money that i get to deposit at the end
of every month
because tomorrow may never come we may
get outlawed our business may be
outlawed
there may be there may be some
horrendous thing that happens that
blows your business up you may have to
move locations and stop everything that
you're doing and you just don't know
and so what we are all exposed to that
we discount on a regular basis is
something called operational risk
we are all exposed right and so if
you're doing this for one year two year
five years
solely with the hope that someday you're
going to sell
well i just want to break the news to
you that you have a 99 to 1 chance of
not actually succeeding doing that
and so you might as well take some money
out of out of the business every month
so you know you make money along the way
and i can promise you having done it
both ways
taking money out of the business every
month is way more fun it's also way less
stressful
all right because this is gonna be the
stuff that allows you to know every
month how we're really doing
when you always leave it in the business
account you always leave it in there you
just don't have a feeling for it
but you should be able to deposit money
in your account this month and be like
this is better than last month or this
is worse than last month and you got to
feel that not just the numbers but
literally what you put into your account
all right and so i'll give you one easy
tactic
um that i was working with one of the
one of the companies that i have um
an equity interest in um let's
let's imagine you've got a big bucket of
money all right this is your bank
account for your business
every month you know after a certain
amount of months what your projected
fixed costs are going to be
all right now what i asked this
entrepreneur to do
uh because he wasn't taking profit out
of the business so i was like hey we're
going to fix this right now
is you need to come up with a line and
you say this is our line this is our
non-negotiable
everything over this we take out every
month all right so everything over a
hundred grand everything over 500 grand
we're going to take out of the business
every single month we're going to clear
this [ __ ] right all the way down to the
bottom
and by doing this you hold yourself
accountable to this
level all right and so to wrap this
puppy up
if you're not taking profit out of the
business i'd highly recommend doing it
number one number two if you're not
measuring net free cash flow you
absolutely should because you're losing
out on one of the most important metrics
this is what charlie marker looks at
this is what warren buffett looks at
this is what i look at not that i'm in
the same category as those guys
but once i switched to this in terms of
my finance and reporting
it really clarified it for everything
just not just for me but also for my
team
all right and when you're looking at
businesses in general if you're thinking
about reinvesting in the business
make sure that the dollars that you're
choosing to reinvest
you're getting the best return on
capital you possibly can
all right so if you're reinvesting the
business and you think you're going to
get 10
back we might as well just put it in the
smp and get that right and not even have
to deal with all the mess
and that's okay if you make a million
bucks a year you make 500 000 a year and
you just put it in the s p
every single year you're gonna be really
really wealthy
right and that's okay and so sometimes
your wealth doesn't necessarily have to
be generated
all entirely from your business or from
a sale that you someday hope to achieve
that may not actually happen
okay that's all i got for you so
that's my my my moment for the day net
free cash flow
track it stack it and make sure that you
empty your bank account every single
month and stack the right account which
is your personal bank account lots of
love catch you soon
bye